une reconversion professionnelle 2.0
l'ancienne nageuse anne-sophie le
parenté ont ex coéquipière de laure
manaudou est licencié au cercle des
nageurs de marseille vient de créer une
place de marché sur internet le site est
dédié à l'achat et à la vente de
matériels et d'équipements sportifs
d'occasion une idée longtemps mûri par
l'ancien athlète
pourquoi pourquoi pas parce que je
trouve que déjà un mois je voulais
entreprendre mais je voulais être
indépendante donc
donc voilà entreprendre et après je vois
là le sport parce que j'ai toujours fait
du sport et que c'est quand même
l'élément je maîtrise le mieux et que je
connais mieux et avec tout le réseau que
j'avais je me suis dit ce serait dommage
de ne pas en profiter pour lancer son
projet là sportif de 40 ans qui habite
arts au concours a décidé de s'associer
à son ami de 33 ans paulino j'ai un
projet né à l'époque où les deux
collaboratrices travailler ensemble au
conseil départemental des yvelines
ça fait 4 4 ans qu'on travaille ensemble
donc voilà progressivement on a appris à
se connaître et puis on avait des on se
complétait bien dans nos compétences
on s'entendait bien donc donc on sait on
s'est lancé dans l'aventuré lancée au
mois de février dans la zone d'activités
promo paul à montigny le bretonneux
d'exporter au contient déjà plus de 3000
références d'ici la fin de l'année plus
de vingt mille produits seront
disponibles sur le site internet pour
booster le nombre de clics des
partenariats avec des sportifs célèbres
sont à l'étude